then the Tea Party came in and for the
first time people lost elections over
spend too much I didn't think he could
lose an election over spend too much I
thought you had to wait till spend too
much became taxed too much then we'd get
you I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
and today we're talking with Grover
Norquist he's the head of Americans for
Tax Reform and he is at the white-hot
center of deliberations over the fiscal
cliff Grover thanks for joining us
absolutely you have been called an
Ayatollah in recent weeks an Ayatollah a
terrorist in evil war law
Lord Jacob Weisberg of slates who
co-wrote a book with Robert Rubin
tweeted Honaker Ceausescu Mubarak
Norquist writing at The Huffington Post
Daryl Roland talked about you as a
Rasputin type figure or like Cardinal
Richelieu what do you make are you
offended that when you're ranked with
history's greatest monster is that they
don't also throw in Jimmy Carter well
this is fascinating because but I offer
people a taxpayer protection pledge and
it's a pledge from a congressman senator
presidential candidate to the American
people the people of their state saying
I will not raise your taxes that a
Washington reformed government cuts
spending when I run into a problem I'm
not raising taxes that's what it is okay
and let's the actual text of your basic
pledge has two points one is that you
have a legislator or candidate sign an
oath saying I oppose any and all efforts
to increase marginal tax rates on
individuals or businesses and the second
part is that you oppose any net
reduction or elimination of deductions
and credits
unless matched by further reductions in
tax rates technical way of saying no net
tax increase okay you can reform at all
you want as long as at the end of the
day it isn't a Trojan horse for higher
taxes so we offer this pledge to
candidates many of them take it 90 plus
percent of all the Republicans in the
House and Senate have made this
commitment 15 governors thousand plus
state legislature mccr ATS and that oh
yes yes several over time usually
Democrats just before they switch to
become Republicans or just before they
get defeated in the next election but
there been several have taken it and
kept it for
period of time I think we're down to one
in the house right now the others have
most recently been defeated that's me
for breaking it for Reagan that said no
Republican has broken the pledge in
Washington DC for 22 years since 1990
when a number followed bush and they
broke that commitment Republicans signed
the pledge because they don't wish to
raise taxes the Democrats and the people
who attack me as Rasputin think that
these Republicans truly want to raise
taxes they they lust after raising taxes
they have signed the pledge for some odd
reason and the only thing keeping them
from raising taxes like they really want
to is that I would call them names it's
so mixed up it's silly but if you're the
left you don't want to say the American
people don't want larger government they
don't want to pay for bigger government
and this is sorting our plans to give
them bigger government so you attacked
me personally well in terms of the
spending equation or let's you know one
of the reasons why you came into the
news again is because people like
Lindsey Graham the Republican senator
from South Carolina and a couple of
other people said well you know what I
signed the you know Grover Norquist
Americans for tax reforms tax pledge but
that was so long ago when I was young
and green and you know now I'm older and
wiser and we're not beholden to you are
you expecting a lot of Republicans to
bust the tax pledge as we come closer to
the fiscal cliff
I don't think so you've had the same
collection of several congressmen and
Senators Lindsey Graham always at the
front of the line saying I might raise
taxes if you gave me a kajillion dollars
in spending restraint if you actually
listen to his conditions on what it
would take to get it tax well I had a
long conversation with him on the phone
after he did this a year or so ago and
he said oh no I'd only vote for tax
increase F and then he got you know
trillions of dollars in unfunded will
undertake away a bull spending restraint
and I said to him you know senator I'm
officially not worried about you know
Democrats ever offering you the trade
you're talking about so no we have
booked Republicans are not us in raising
taxes some fantasize that there is a
Gift of the Magi deal where the
Republicans would give away higher taxes
and Democrats
would give away their entitlements and
reform them the Democrats never intend
to reform entitlement what what's so
perfect about the tax rate now you know
our overall tax plan now is that the
amount of revenue it might raise that we
should say we're never gonna raise taxes
we're never going to increase in that
taxes
well taxes are too high in spending is
too high step one is don't raise taxes
because tax the total tax burden and the
total spending run should be
significantly lower for most of American
history it's been much lower I mean one
to three percent four percent okay well
since about 1950 and you know it gets
dicey in the past couple of years but
you know we're looking at the federal
level tax revenue as a percentage of GDP
is around seventeen eighteen percent is
that is that the you know the moral
number is that metaphysical certitude
that it should never be more than that
well it should never be more than that
because it should be significantly less
okay and this is when you say
significantly less how much was I'm with
Samuel Gompers less or less and when we
have less less okay fabien small
government person there's no number
there's no floor under which I'd say oh
my goodness you can't cut the government
any more that the government was bloated
in 1852 okay so when you deal with the
pledge the pledge is step one in a
two-step process first don't raise taxes
second spend less okay
Republicans don't want to you know they
don't want to raise taxes but they also
don't want to cut spending they have
been party to avasta you know increases
in federal spending certainly and under
Bush total federal spending when he had
a Republican Congress went out something
like sixty sixty-five percent overall
adjusted for inflation so what kind of
spending cuts do we need to have I mean
on your website you say categorically
spending should be government should be
spending less than it currently does how
much less well you can reform government
over time rather easily compared to
cutting it texts by tomorrow morning and
that is and this is where I think the
Ryan plan is a good outline you block
grant the major welfare means-tested
programs
as we did in 96 with aid to families
with dependent children you do food
stamps you do well what's good about
Block Grant well it puts a cap on how
much you're spending sends it out to 50
states 50 states can figure out how to
spend the money more effectively and how
to save less with one national welfare
program it's hard to tell whether that
program is hurting or helping because
everybody in the country is affected the
same way you have fifty ones it's easier
to see
California's working in Texas isn't or
vice-versa and you can see what works
and what doesn't work with Medicare they
do the the premium program which also
saves a great deal of money over time oh
you know by 2040 you take spending from
twenty three twenty four percent of GDP
down to sixteen percent of GDP and
declining so is that enough is it fast
enough not necessarily but every single
Republican in the house saved two guys
has voted for that plan that is the
modern Republican Party's position well
let's talk about specific cuts though I
mean because you know the economy isn't
gonna be around in 40 years if we're you
know if it takes that long we're screwed
we need to pass the Ryan plan next four
years okay and then what but what what
can we be cutting now I mean we're
spending we've had four trillion dollar
deficits in a row what do we need to be
cutting spending on I mean that's the
out of the three big-ticket items you'd
Medicare and Social Security and Defense
you know can we should we be cutting
these now or putting in place the
restraints that need to be there yes but
I would argue that in each case reform
is a better way to go than quote-unquote
cutting I'd much rather take Social
Security and turn it into a defined
contribution plan then shop at ten or
twenty percent across-the-board first of
all the one just irritates people and it
doesn't at the end of the day make it
self-sustaining a 401 K where people
save their FICA taxes and then have
money when they retired with something
like that how do you pay for people who
are already in the system you just
figure out a way to do that oh it's
chilly did is they floated a bond to
cover it I mean they're different ways
to do it I'm in favor of the the way to
get us fastest to the most people owning
their own 401 k's rather than trust
the government for their retirement to
d-link your retirement from government
power to d-link your health care and
old-age from government and you talked a
bit about Medicare what about what about
defense spending I mean you're a
high-profile Republican who is in favor
of cutting defense spending right Cheryl
Oteri's absolutely how do we do that as
quickly and effectively as possible when
the Democrats and some Republicans get
more money they put it into retirement
benefits that's never stopped an al
Qaeda guy more bases in the United
States doesn't necessarily do that their
whole series of reforms that need to be
made procurement reforms this is what
Rumsfeld the big tragedy of Rumsfeld was
he came in to wrestle the retirement and
procurement to the to the ground and he
got sidetracked with the need to occupy
need the desire to occupy Iraq and
Afghanistan and you believe those were
have been disastrous well let me start
this way the overthrowing the Taliban
and overthrowing the bathurst regime in
Iraq we're not necessarily bad ideas I
didn't oppose him at the time and they
didn't cost very much money but then
staying and occupying the place for 10
years and deciding we're going to turn
it into Kansas that was expensive in
lives and in our where weaker country
compared to other countries because of
that decision it has harmed our standing
as a power and our capacity to exercise
power when necessary in our own defense
so spending where money doesn't
necessarily buy you more defense anymore
than giving the teachers union more
money gets kids educated or handing out
welfare makes people better off and
conservatives need to look at the
Defense Department the way they do all
the rest of government it's nice that
it's actually mentioned in the
Constitution that's a plus but at the
same time there's no reason to waste
money or spend it unnecessarily in that
zone I think you've got a Republican
Party that's rethinking the occupations
of Iraq and Afghanistan
I asked three congressmen on a panel
that Cato ran a couple years ago in a
private conversation what percentage of
Republicans in the House would say that
the decision to stay in occupy Iraq was
a mistake and all three said all and I
said Whitman let me let me restate the
point I said again
I thought they misunderstood all in
private all wouldn't they say that in
public that was sort of too close to the
Bush administration and at one point
that was Bush's war and there was this
bizarre notion the Democrats supported
the war in Bosnia and Yugoslavia and the
Republicans thought it was outrageous
and then Republicans supported
Afghanistan in Iraq and Democrats
thought it was outrageous I mean if
you're really in favor of wars on
partisan basis have you thought it
through in terms of the nation's needs
well this seems to be the case though I
mean that predictably if one party
occupies the White House then the other
party in Congress is against that war
and vice versa which is what probably
one of the reasons why defense spending
is up something like 70 percent since
2000 suggests people are not giving it
serious thought well let's you know to
come back to the fiscal cliff how does
this how is this gonna play out
according to you I mean because we got
John Boehner it seems like he is
sweating bullets and he's trying to
throw more and more pieces of bacon at
Obama to go after how does the fiscal
cliff end I have recommended and they
haven't taken my recommendation today
that they have all negotiations be on
c-span because exactly what you said is
happening Boehner is making these
recommendations you have no idea it's a
black box what the Obama people are
tantalising with and so it just sounds
like Boehner is busy conceding which may
be what's happening but it's not clear
because they played the same game with
him two years ago run the debt ceiling
thing and he wasn't taken to the
cleaners and he got what he wanted
so I hesitate to immediately jump in and
say because the White House put out a
press release on ax Boehner didn't bro X
that said there are a sheer this is not
a fiscal cliff this is a very bumpy road
with a bunch of bumps in the road there
is the January first effort when the
Obamacare tax increases begin the bush
tax increases go away unless something
is done and we get the sequester a
trillion dollars plus of savings unless
Congress which seems pretty much off the
table right I mean it seems like that
the sequester cuts which of course were
put in in last summer's budget deal or
in 2011 nobody's talking about
rescinding those cuts that which is a
good thing it's a very good thing and
you saw Mitch McConnell the Republican
leader in the Senate say we are not
raising taxes
to stop the sequester the Republicans
have always said if you want to come up
with a different way to save money as in
the same guaranteed manner the sequester
does run we'll talk about it but the
number stays and the Conservatives
including the Hawks and the house have
all said the number stays and since the
DS have no interest in changing the
structure I think that's the one good P
so what what will happen on January
first taxes will go up
I think Obama's planning and driving us
over the cliff for the following reason
he needs an excuse for the failure of
the next four years and if we go over
the cliff and even scramble back in days
or weeks or a few months and and at the
end of the day nobody's taxes actually
change in 2013 with withholding he will
still run around going well the lousy
economy of my second term which I can no
longer blame on Bush because people are
laughing at me I now blame on going over
the cliff because what's gonna happen is
you have a trillion dollars plus of
Obamacare taxes you have hundreds of
billions and trillions of dollars of
regulations being dumped on the economy
they had four years of writing
regulations that they didn't tell
anybody about and they're now coming
down like a hailstorm and it's gonna be
very and so this is beyond the Obamacare
stuff that's coming online now we're
starting to learn dodd-frank and things
like that energy stuff you know the one
thing the president bragged about was
energy growing up in his regs will now
Jerry you know your power is more
clearly in the Republican Party is a
time for Boehner to go or you know
because even when you talk about the
debt reduction a debt ceiling deal that
was cut in 2011 that's a pretty awful
deal where we'll give you two billion or
we'll give you two trillion dollars in
bumping up the debt ceiling in exchange
you know we'll we'll give that to you in
the near term very near-term for two
trillion dollars in cuts spending you
know over the next ten years I mean this
is a I mean it's like bargaining with
wimpy for hamburgers or something like
that but actually since that is the best
deal we've ever cut on increase in the
debt ceiling it's always been for free
right I like that as the Boehner world
now what I like more like present value
two trillion dollars instead of two
trillion dollars over ten years
absolutely but I think that that is now
the minimum negotiating position for
a debt ceiling increase in the future
and that is a good and healthy thing
Boehner and Mitch McConnell in the
middle of all this debate have restated
that that is the position of the of
their caucuses that's very very helpful
I think look we need to hold the
Republican majority in the House
committed to a Ryan size reform which is
six trillion dollars in less spending
over the next decade compared to what
but I mean that's six trillion dollars
over the next decade out of what fifty
trillion dollars and expected spending
so you're talking about to do going East
instead of West and we're talking about
progress not a solution to all the world
flows but we need a Senate that becomes
as serious as the house that could
happen in two years and we need a
different president then you can
actually pass some legislation between
now and then the Republicans who want to
cut spending maybe not all but the ones
you want to cut spending have two levers
debt ceiling you want a debt ceiling
increase because Obama is going to keep
bumping into it you have to give us
stuff which would they get last time not
as much as we'd like but progress to the
continuing resolution and this is the
more subtle power because the Democrats
in the Senate haven't passed a budget
for three to four years they do a
continuing resolution will it just keep
spending money with the following
provides us that ends March April and
what the Republicans did and what
Boehner organized well two years ago was
we will give you another two weeks of
continuing resolution for eight billion
in discrete spending cuts ones that
you'd actually endorse them were passed
you were lying when you immerse them but
the President Obama couldn't shut the
government down to stop a teeny spending
cut that he'd endorsed and so they were
going three yards in a cloud of dust the
Republican freshmen were going you know
we need more faster and they let that
lapse what we need to do if has the
discipline to take three yards in a
cloud of dust small discrete spending
cuts no I mean you've written and and
talked about how the continuing
resolutions have actually been a good
thing we haven't had a budget a real
budget in it about three years because
it basically kept spending level or even
trending down
a bit do you are you shaking you know in
your boots about the idea that we might
actually have a budget to vote on next
year so we'll certainly be bigger than a
continuing resolution yes but I would I
will take the continuing resolution
that's one pressure point they actually
want to do a budget if the Senate wanted
to do a budget that would be very
helpful because if the DS passed the
budget they want we can beat a lot of
people in two years if they're willing
to come down to reasonable levels that
the house would agree to then you
actually can do better than a CR but
we're gonna have a four year tutorial on
spending and fights on spending how many
more and we'll end with this but how
many more tutorials for your tutorials
on spending do we need because I mean
this goes back to a question you know
reason as a libertarian group a lot of
people are tired of the Republicans who
say their first less spending and
smaller government we saw this with
george w bush and a republican congress
that was you know totally powerful they
give us a four year or six year tutorial
on how to blow out the jams and on
spending why should anybody think that
the republicans if only you know the
next time they'll finally learn their
lesson yep because this is the post tea
party republican party reagan changed
the republican party into the party of
lower marginal tax rates the pledge
helped make at the party the level raise
taxes period but it then was still the
party that would spend too much money
bush never thought about reducing
spending it was never on his list of
things to do and whenever there was a
crisis they spent more money not less
then the tea party came in and for the
first time people lost elections over
spend too much i didn't think he could
lose an election over spend too much
that's had to wait to spend too much
became taxed too much then we'd get you
right but you know a lot 83 freshman
republican in a year when spending was d
issue about taxes not regulating
spending that is a republican party much
more attuned in washington DC to
spending the appropriators have been if
not neutered really cut back the fact
that they took away their earmark
capacity I mean earmarks were the broken
windows a big big spending and so it is
a much stronger committed party on
spending
we need the Tea Party in the batarians
within and without the Republican Party
to maintain that discipline who were the
leaders of the Tea Party that are in the
Senate in the house of Congress give me
two names in the Senate Scott the guy is
replacing him in its gonna is going to
be one of the leaders on on that I would
certainly Scalise
the leader of the Republican Study
Committee the caucus of row 60% of the
Republicans you caucuses as
conservatives Johnson Ron Johnson of
Wisconsin senator both a Tea Party win
or a business guy in a serious player
and spent Ted Cruz same thing out of
Texas what about the house who are the
big guns in the house that are gonna
keep spending down in the house actually
watch for Ryan because he has to
maintain that brand of his is the
spending guy not just that the tax
people and Cantor's gonna want to play a
role in the same zone but if you want
another leadership of the moderate
Republican Party over the next ten years
look at the 30 Republican governors
Walker took what was once considered an
unreachable ceiling of Republican
activism on defunding public sector
unions and school choice and I think
that's now the floor you want to run for
president you have to be at least as
good as Walker as bold and and and brave
as Walker was Wow and you see Bobby
Jindal in Louisiana I mean there are a
whole series of Governors that have
started that process watch Brownback of
Kansas there is a state that's moving on
all fronts I mean there's we're gonna be
able to judge a guy not by his promises
but by whether he's passed at the state
level the kind of tax and spending
restraint that we want to see in
Washington DC that's a lot more
important than some congressman or
senator who if they ever accomplished
anything they're 50 other senators I did
the same thing they did how do you know
if he or she is doing stuff governor's
okay well Grover Norquist Ayatollah
terrorists East German dictator tax
anti-tax activists thanks for talking
with reason TV thank you
I'm Nick Gillespie
you